Today is a very special day because we are
starting to go to hatred mail that relates
to the presumption that Donald Trump will
be reelected in 2020 now I don't totally disagree
that that is not only a plausible but a a
moderately likely scenario. But before we
get to that, a quick reminder, what is hatred
that mail?
Because Mexico is still paying for the wall,
right? I mean that's what he said at all the
campaign. Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom,
okay. So this is once again, hatred mail that
is starting to deal with the particulars of
what hatreds believe is going to happen. Uh,
in November of 2020 let's take a look at this
week's Patriot mail.
You pricks. You should know better. Do you?
I am sick to death of the self. Righteous,
arrogant, like you rotten hell mega hats forever
and winning even longer. Will you cry in November
2020s. God dull. I hope to hell you life streams
so we can all see it for myself.
Yeah. So listen, uh, I'm going to be doing
plenty of live streaming. I don't know that
I will be crying. And again, as, as I've said
before, the, this is a conversation that many
progressive shows have had. We all know that
Donald Trump being reelected would be far
better for our programs and our businesses
then. I dunno, it's certainly better than
just Joe Biden becomes president of the United
States. Uh, but I've not seen any progressive
hosts say, and therefore I want Trump to be
reelected. I recognize Trump is good for business
and I want him got as soon as possible. But
uh, you, you may not be wrong. It is certainly
feasible that a Donald Trump will be reelected
to another four years. I did a commentary
about that on the Monday show. Fight, hatred,
autism by signing up for a membership@joinpackman.com
using the coupon code hatred 40, it saves
you 40%.
Uh, and it makes hatred cry that their hatred,
autism is not accomplishing anything for their
political ideology.